un débat politique sur france 3 une
candidate en marche qui semblent
déstabilisés
à deux jours du premier tour des
législatives il n'en fallait pas plus
pour faire le buzz médiatique sur les
réseaux sociaux repris même sur les
chats nationale elle l'aurait fait
n'importe quelle que le tissage parce
qu'on n'a pas tout compris après sa main
emmanuel macron -votre mélenchon je
pense
le programme que je soutiens donc que je
n'aime pas le programme d emmanuel matot
ajoutez à cela une autre vidéo moqueuse
posté par ses détracteurs pour ça vienne
colboc candidat dans la 4e
circonscription pas facile d'entrer dans
l'arène
elle le reconnaît sans vergogne à une
était pas prête pour ce débat pas encore
rompu à l'exercice mais ne s'avoue pas
vaincu pour autant
bourbon dit donc cette façon je rebondis
effectivement c'est par les coups qu'on
apprend c'est ça ma façon d'apprendre
d'habitude
alors effectivement bas je joue le jeu
donc voilà j'ai fait de belles réunions
publiques depuis ces attaques depuis ses
premières vidéos sorties pense que j'ai
une formule de survie en tout cas de
capacité de rebondir on découvre des
ressources et des compétences
incroyable toujours est il que pour ses
adversaires cet épisode médiatique est
tout simplement due par benny invité sur
le plateau de télé tour laurent baumel
candidat ps sortant et politique aguerri
n'a pas hésité à torpiller un peu plus
son opposante qu'elle est conditionnée
du mal à remplir pour pouvoir exercer
cette fonction difficile
non à l'évidence pas pour le moment qui
serait si vous voulez dangereux et
finalement pas bon pour les habitants de
cette circonscription
c'est d'avoir demain à représentant à
paris au parlement qui symbolise
certaine manière les lacunes de cette
nouvelle génération de députés autour
des donateurs réponse de la principale
intéressée
alors les compétences ou les conditions
minimales requises ça dépend
à qui on parle de coran parle pour
certains pour avoir déjà été député
nouhad députés pour avoir ces conditions
pour d'autres c'est alors un parcours
professionnel
c'est savoir s'entourer reste à savoir
si ce buzz médiatique desservira
réellement la candidate et son parti ou
bien au contraire attirera l'attention
en lui laissant une chance de poursuivre
ses premiers pas en politique